aprendimos en los vídeos sobre torca que
la torca que lo denotamos con la letra
tau era igual a la fuerza por la
distancia verdad que en este vídeo voy a
denotar lo con ere y ya verán por qué y
esta fuerza de hecho para para
contextualizar más y que quede más claro
de donde salía era teníamos digamos esta
barra que y aquí teníamos el pivote o
donde estaba fija y suponíamos que
aplicamos una fuerza perpendicular a
esta barra vamos a llamarle a esa fuerza
efe y esta barra tenía una distancia r
digamos que ésta esta medida r verdad
entonces de aquí es de donde sale la
torca verdad simplemente es esta fuerza
aplicada de forma perpendicular a la
barra y al hacer la multiplicación de la
fuerza por el radio obteníamos el valor
de la torca ahora también sabemos que la
fuerza es igual a la masa por la
aceleración verdad masa por aceleración
y luego multiplicamos por r
ahora bien qué era la aceleración pues
esencialmente la aceleración es el
cambio de la velocidad con el tiempo
verdad entonces tendremos que la torca
es igual a la masa por el cambio de la
velocidad de gente y estoy poniendo de
es el cambio de la velocidad entre el
cambio en el tiempo es decir que tanto
cambia la velocidad al cambiar el tiempo
x eres verdad y ahora bien si nosotros
pensamos que no hay torta que estamos
que estamos pensando si no hay torta es
decir 'te out es igual a cero esto viene
de qué
de pensar que a lo mejor este este
digamos movimiento va a tener que ser
hasta cierto punto constante que quiero
decir con eso si la torca es cero quiere
decir que esto de aquí el cambio de la
velocidad por el radio debe ser
constante de hecho todo debe ser
constante verdad todo esto debe ser
constante muy bien entonces lo que es la
masa por la velocidad por el radio es
una cantidad constante muy bien esto es
constante y esto puedes pensarlo como
que viene de las leyes de newton verdad
si aquí pensamos que al aplicar esta
fuerza este esta barra empieza a moverse
de forma circular verdad entonces
podemos pensar que esta barra se va a
mover con la misma velocidad todo el
tiempo verdad y esto viene esencialmente
de las leyes de newton verdad sí sí sí
esta barra estaba en reposo pues si no
le aplicamos alguna fuerza externa pues
seguirá en reposo verdad o si está
girando
digamos a cierta velocidad pues seguirá
girando a esa misma velocidad si no le
hacemos nada ni nada externo y de hecho
nosotros aprendimos en el vídeo anterior
que la velocidad angular denotada con la
letra omega era la de la rapidez más
bien entre el radio verdad el radio del
movimiento circular que esto genera
ahora bien si nosotros despejamos quien
es la velocidad la rapidez perdón la
rapidez es igual a la velocidad angular
por el radio muy bien entonces si
nosotros sustituimos esta cantidad en
este lado lo que vamos a tener es lo
siguiente masa por la velocidad perdón
por la rapidez que es omega por el omega
r
y también tenemos que multiplicar por
esta otra ere y esto que nos da esto es
igual a la masa por la velocidad angular
por el radio al cuadrado y esta cantidad
tiene que ser constante verdad otra
forma de haberlo pensado desde la
siguiente forma
tao tao que es la torsión era masa es
masa por el cambio en la velocidad es
decir
y ponerlo así por el cambio en la
velocidad entre el cambio en el tiempo
por r muy bien pero la velocidad era o
mega por r entonces esto es igual a la
masa por el cambio que hay en omega por
el omega por r pero si estamos
suponiendo que esta cantidad es decir
que que la velocidad angular de este
movimiento se mantiene y pues el radio
sigue siendo el mismo porque la barra no
cambia quiere decir entonces que esta
cantidad no cambia de hecho es ella
misma verdad esto es igual a la masa x
por mega por r por r que es r cuadrada
verdad entonces son dos formas de
obtener esta fórmula y de hecho por eso
es que esto es lo que conocemos como el
momento angular momento angular y si no
hay torsión verdad perdón o no quiso
decir torsión quise decir torca sino
aitor k el momento angular se conserva
es decir es el mismo en todo momento y
para pensar en esto vamos a hacer un
ejemplo digamos que tenemos no sé
tenemos algún objeto girando
está un círculo con más o menos un
intento de círculo muy bien digamos que
tenemos no sé cómo alguna especie de
brazo robótico ok que tiene agarrado
algún objeto digamos que tiene aquí un
objeto y para que después podamos
completar el ejercicio piensen que tiene
ahí como una coyuntura digamos donde
puede hacer cierta flexión digamos que
el brazo tiene una distancia de 8 metros
verdad
qué vamos a dejarlo por este momento así
vamos a pensar además que la velocidad
angular la velocidad angular que él
pusimos con amarillo la velocidad
angular va a ser de 10 radiales por
segundo sobre segundo ok
esta es nuestra velocidad angular ahora
bien cuál es el momento angular que
lleva este objeto que está girando en
digamos en esta dirección
ok pues simplemente lo calculamos verdad
es la masa que tenga masa por 10 por el
radio al cuadrado por el radio es 8 así
que al cuadrado es 64 y esto que es 640
por la masa muy bien por la masa
entonces qué pasaría si ahora este brazo
robótico
debido a que tiene una coyuntura y se
flexiona y deja ahora al objeto justo en
este punto
digamos que estos son mide 4 metros muy
bien de aquí aquí son 4 metros
esto de aquí son 4 metros entonces qué
es lo que cuáles sería el momento
angular en este caso tendríamos masa por
la velocidad que ahora no sabemos no
sabemos qué velocidad lleve pero sí
sabemos que la distancia se recortó a la
mitad y hay que elevarla al cuadrado
entonces tendremos 4 al cuadrado esto
será será 16 déjenme ponerlo en el color
que habíamos mantenido esto es wv 1 por
4 al cuadrado que son 16 pero como el
con el momento angular se conserva
quiere decir que esto debe ser igual a
640 m muy bien en la misma masa porque
es el mismo objeto
entonces las masas se cancelan y podemos
concluir que w
1 es igual a 640 entre 16 ahora cuánto
es 640 entre 16 pues esto por ejemplo
podemos sacar justo 16 y nos queda
verdad vale 40 que es mucho pero
muchísimo más rápido que la velocidad
original que llevaba verdad y esto es
simplemente porque es proporcional al
radio al cuadrado de hecho tú ya has
visto este tipo de fenómenos por ejemplo
cuando estás viendo las olimpiadas de
invierno y ves gente que está patinando
entonces imagínate un patinador piensa
cuando está por ejemplo girando con los
brazos extendidos y después empieza a
girar y girar y cuando meten los brazos
resulta que van mucho más rápido es
justamente este mismo efecto verdad y
eso ocurre porque el momento angular es
proporcional al radio al cuadrado
entonces espero que al menos esto te
haya resultado muy interesante esta edad
como siempre dar mucha explicación para
muchos fenómenos que vemos en el día a
día y además además este tipo de
fórmulas nos ayudan a resolver problemas
sobre velocidad es bueno nos vemos
pronto